brian walter congratulations both of you
guys are moving forward into the next
round
in round three of the competition we're
gonna be sending you guys back to your
home forges
to build an iconic weapon from history
and that weapon is
the sword of saladin this 12th century
sword belonged to saladin
a powerful muslim leader and the first
sultan of egypt in syria
believed to be forged from steel far
superior than
any other weapon of the time the sword
is rumored to be the sharpest in history
featuring a thin edge geometry the
lightweight curved blade is designed to
effortlessly deliver deep cuts
and lethal chops with the help of this
deadly weapon saladin
founded a dynasty that ruled much of the
middle east for the 12th
and 13th centuries the sword is a
prominent feature of a statue of
memorializing saladin
that stands in front of the ancient city
of damascus in syria
i'm absolutely excited it's a lot longer
than what i normally build but
yeah we can do this you guys will only
have four days to complete this weapon
so we'll see when you get back good luck
[Music]
we're back here baronowski nike tool and
good old springville new york
i'm ready to get after it my biggest
concern is
time management when you're on a time
challenge like this
every minute is precious curve's going
pretty well
i'm done with my forging head straight
to the grinder and start cleaning
this thing up make it look right
time to quench
[Music]
that's the sound of success right there
back at my home forge making a sword
with a with a bend in it and such a
steep arc like this is worrying me a
little bit
[Music]
uh i've not done a heat treat on
something of this shape before
close i'm a little worried about the
heat treat
away we go
[Music]
oh yeah that's it
i got the quillian on it i like it and i
get pommel
built pretty much the shape i want this
is a emerald dyed box elder burl
i want it to look jeweled without
actually being jeweled
so i got everything pretty well rough
fit here i'm just kind of
pecking away at it going slowly nobody
is going to be able to complain about
that handle
at all this has been a hell of a ride
but i hope that can uh
bring me home the bacon bladesmiths
welcome
to the keel test to find out what kind
of lethal damage your weapons will do i
will take your version of saladin's
sword
and deliver some lethal blows on this
ram carcass
brand near first you ready for this no
but i guess you got to do what you got
to do
absolutely let's do it to see that
animal sitting there with the horns
hanging out
uh it's nerve-wracking
it's pretty hard on a blade so i'm not
sure what's going to happen
all right brian let's talk about your
version of saladin's sword here
i noticed you have something inscribed
in there what is that that is saladin in
arabic
very cool very cool now your edge
you have a sharp edge this is a very
tough
ram carcass on the neck chops it cut
deeply
and of course on the body it cut through
in three slices
overall sir your weapon
will kill thank you sir all right walter
your turn sir are you ready
let's make some ram chops all right
them bones and a ram those those are no
joke their hides
are as tough as leather their fur is
abrasive like sandpaper
this is a legit test i'm slightly
freaking out on the inside right now
exactly this man
[Music]
all right walter first up your edge
this is a wicked sharp grind
actually when you know it sings to me
when i just touch it and pull it out
it is sharp cutting through hair a
thick spine and into the meat overall
sir
your weapon will kill thank you sir
all right gentlemen you know what time
it is it's time for the strength test
now saladin's army in the 12th century
would have faced off against men wearing
chain mail
carrying shields and probably a helmet
now to test your blades
construction overall durability i'll be
hacking into our armored warriors here
brian you're up go ahead
wow all right brian
blades this sharp and with this kind of
edge geometry often take
a fairly substantial rolling when they
go up against armor
yours really didn't i mean there's a
three spots i can feel
if i run my fingernail along it just
beautiful job well done
thank you sir all right walter you're up
let's do it okay
oh nice
all right walter there's a little bit of
a glinting and a little bit of a rough
spot here here
and maybe here other than that this
blade still has a wicked edge on it
curvature's really really nice you
nailed it scale
right on well done thank you sir you bet
close race all right bladesmiths
welcome to the sharpness test to find
out how
sharp your weapons are i will take your
weapon and i will cut through these
egyptian rugs now i'm looking for clean
cuts
brian you're up first you ready yes sir
let's do this
all right brian let's talk about your
blade here it
is razor sharp as i punctured and cut
through the carpet
there were very clean cuts overall sir
your edge
it will cut thank you all right walter
are you ready
absolutely let's do this
so that ring
all right walters talk about your weapon
here
razor sharp it was easy to penetrate
very easy to drag across these are
very clean cuts overall sir your weapon
you'll cut thank you sir
all right gentlemen the judges have made
the decision
today's champion is
walter what what
i'm just a jock i can't believe this
now unfortunately brian that means you
did not win today this is the closest
decision i have ever had to make
ever brian you brought us
an absolutely beautiful weapon it tested
fantastically
it felt fantastic in my hand we made
this decision based on the
smallest of details and it came down to
the curvature of the blade
yours just has a little wobble in it the
other doesn't
it's that close you should be incredibly
proud of that blade
and it was an absolute pleasure to be
able to wield it
thank you very much brian unfortunately
that means you didn't make the cut today
i'm gonna have to ask you to
head off to porch floor bro it's been an
honor
i'm a little disappointed to not be in
the winter circle but very proud of the
fact that dave said it was one of the
hardest decisions they've ever had to
make
feel i did pretty good
well walter congratulations buddy you
are the fortune fire champ and you'll be
going out of here with a check
for ten thousand dollars how do you feel
i don't even know right now
i won i can't believe it 10 grand
there's nothing to sneeze at but i want
to take a portion of it and donate to
some kind of cancer organization
cancer's taking a lot of people away
from me that i care about
took my dad and i want to be able to
give back a little bit
what a wild ride
you